miley cyrus hits the stage and the  campaign trail  the singer honored comedian Bill Murray  who received the Mark Twain prize for  American humor sunday night in  Washington DC  oh I got to stone  later bill suggested miley tried the  song again she nailed the performance  and according to ABC that's the version  viewers will see when the ceremony is  aired Friday on PBS oh my god I freaked  out and on Saturday miley was getting  political in Virginia campaigning for  Hillary Clinton at George Mason  University stay stronger together can  you not hear me stay here my site went  dorm to dorm speaking to students about  the importance of voting it's just  direct anything with the kids are  related to Philip  you